let us end it's cold
we're already inside
like this is my home all right let me do
it again oh he's gonna do it again
oh this is good this is good who's there
i i don't want to do it i changed my
mind all right all right
knock knock but you're already inside
no no i got it i got this i got this
[Music]
let us leave oh let us leave
you should have said
all right come this way come this way
i've made a museum for you and
i want to show you is this what you made
today yeah yeah yeah
we if we gallivant this way all right
stream is fixed nice
oh great we're good to go my stream is
also
um hasn't had a single problem
uh if you come across these lily pads
nice
we can see uh ignore that it says the up
there this is the
what well i see it alright oh is that a
photo shoot
okay five is here hey i won't look i'll
take one step at a time
no if we take oh
you do the tour sorry i just yeah okay
i'll take you through the tour
yeah if you look over here i i've taken
it upon myself to
get the picture that every single news
outlet has ever used
it's that one and the one from barnes
and noble yeah
yeah yeah there you go husband or
mar mark yeah i couldn't fit marcia so i
just put that makes sense
yeah i should call her that really
here's my here's
way more this is literally my google
image search
i like it is it yeah like you look up
pewdiepie and it says
fabulous yeah i feel like i've seen this
photo a million times
do you so you remember taking this photo
yeah
yeah yeah well it's from a video it's
from like
yeah long ago that's so interesting
because i remember seeing this photo
no way i was yeah yeah when i was
a child like seven years ago
you know did you vibe when i was like
14.
did i fly with this yeah cute i'm gonna
be honest with you i was not the biggest
pewdiepie fan ah
you were when you were scared of barrels
i was like
it's not really my thing hey hey hey you
could kill me
but now now you're like the the
brofist guy and i love that dude i love
that that's
fun yeah okay you like the broken that's
okay anyways let's close that no one
needs to see that
uh over here is marcia i've tried to
reconstruct her the best i could
i don't know what your wife looks like
me neither
yeah i think that's it is this good i'm
i just kind of imagined her with like
cold no this is marching
it might it's supposed to be mark come
on
marg oh sorry yeah well i could fit it
there so
you'll also notice i couldn't fit well
actually i probably could have i can
tell you put a lot of
effort into this yeah it looks like what
made you go with like a pacman
kind of hue oh no see that's see that's
her hair
oh yeah so that's her hair and then
the rest of her is um marcia
angel beautiful yep that's
who you married
i i like to imagine you wake up next to
this thing every day
uh yeah anyways here's the photoshop of
us together
on our wedding day okay by the way
wait this is wait what what's wrong
oh what the [ __ ] i can look at myself
this is so weird uh
sorry sorry
just ruined i appreciate the blue and uh
yellow by the way
it's a good scheme yeah
i thought you were this is not marzia
what did you do
oh i mean it looks just like i like i
like how even in uh
minecraft the low pixel you can tell
that just
yeah yeah no i mean it's
i didn't even make that you know if you
look close you can tell it's not
authentic
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah i i
mean i'll be honest i don't even know
who made that
did you feel weird photoshopping night
did you feel like you didn't admit
like i said didn't make that was that is
that weird there is something i did make
in here
though okay here's here's here's the
thumbnail for your video
uh hey we got this psyche sweet what's
up yeah well
well look over to the right look up
there uh that's uh
our best friend challenge video that we
made together a long while ago
i don't know who the guy on the right is
is that me
say you with that glasses yeah that's me
you couldn't tell that that was me
it looks just like me i feel like this
is one i have to go closer
i don't i don't think that's your hair
bro
do you know what i look like take off
your armor
yeah yeah
too far i hadn't showered oh no no no no
that's pj
that's my friend pj
you used the wrong photo
i don't uh
okay yeah so
to your left i made a little sookie
market in here you oh
this is nice hey yeah you got the space
vest
oh nice
you guys you guys have been out of that
for a while is that true are we actually
sold out
i mean that's what the website says
you've been trying to get one
i would dude i'll send you one no
problem yeah
that's exactly why i did this collab
nice oh god
and then uh sold out logo t-shirt uh we
still
still got the pencil set guys i just
don't know why
it's not selling you know i mean i don't
i don't know why people wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i
don't think it's a it's a sake glass
it's not a pencil say you know like
it's a drinking glass it's a small drink
but i guess you could put pencils in it
or your flute it said pencil set did it
really
yeah now you must have gotten wrong it's
a soccer glass
see i i copied that straight from the
site hey
hey
let it go
oh you did that i
i i'm on the same page bro i got you
hey it's men hey yup that's your dog
all right nice no oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i had to you know that's why i put it
there that's can you please spawn him in
again at least
no i i honestly i don't even know how
that got there
you just made everyone hate you it
happens
you know it's not the first time look at
this
barrels remember when you screamed at
those no no no no
no no no no i'm not doing this i'm not
doing this so you get spin back
are you for real i'm for real i'm
leaving
put him back i don't even know where
you'll go i mean
once you leave it's just not going to be
very good well there won't be any more
knock knock okay or not that's not the
first time that this has happened
with with another creativity where i've
killed their dog and then they've
threatened to
go do something else and i've said the
exact same thing i don't know what
you're gonna do then
okay well watch me seems like a
challenge
all right so so i just don't know where
you thought you were going to go
adios that's destroyed adios amigos and
rather immature
for
yeah but it was funny yeah yeah
okay now watch this yeah
yeah i mean that's about what i expected
to happen yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so
don't fall i won't fall oops all right
well oopsie i didn't get out of there
i'll i'll get you spin back i'll get you
spin back
okay thank you
uh i'm sorry i don't know what that was
i don't i've never even heard that
coming on my body
i hate this experience so far
i haven't even done anything yeah can
you say that what did i do
did i do something wrong um
i mean you did kill my dog yeah but it
was like funny right
no spins back spins back where are you
digging to
oh okay i guess i'll come back
you ever thought about getting a job um
like what where are you going you're not
going you're not coming back
am i not digging up
going down that's that doesn't make any
sense
okay beat me up then please
no i just spawned another dog oh hell
yeah
look what you did all right could you
please we can have one each
where's the other one
here i like that here here here here
here's some bones
thank you all right
don't kill him again please he has your
diamonds do you have my diamonds
huh was that
huh
you know what huge ever since you got
here you've been a real
thorn in myself
hey hey get him
yes get him spent dog your dog is really
struggling actually
i don't know what you're expecting to
happen but your dog is just not having
it
the [ __ ] is happening get him sweat
yeah yeah even screaming yeah
no no eat the boat
eat the boat no i hit the boat
oh he's fine okay all right all right
too distracting let's leave the let's
leave the dogs out of this
yeah okay yeah okay over here we have a
swedish flag
uh-huh and then over here we have
swedish fish
i got all your favorite stuff nice we
don't actually have swedish vision
sweden
what's the point
[Laughter]
do you like swedish fish i've never had
them
really i just i just all i listen my
knowledge of swedish fish is limited to
the fact that it is fat free
it's assorted and it's it's fat free
that's pretty good
it says so i mean i if we're gonna take
it
it's funny value it's funny because in
in sweden we have swedish fish but we
just call it fish
i get it hell yeah that's good that's
good
very good uh in america we color fish uh
fish as well
huh okay all right what next we got
uh floor gang is over here i saw that
very nice
it's race though if anything it should
be you know slam down
but i'll take it
he didn't even notice i died he didn't
even notice i fell into the hole
yeah i didn't do that on purpose
my plan worked out i knew it
you fool i wasn't was you didn't plan
that
you didn't even you didn't even know how
to set up your stream correctly
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
come on i'm sorry for killing you this
one i just
hate how i see it all right okay
all right i gotta get back down there
and get my stuff
before d spawns okay now we're now we're
even
i think that's fine now we're even now
yeah does everyone in your chat not hate
me anymore now
uh let's see chat what do you think
what's the consensus
forgive forgive and forget that's why i
always say
i don't know i think it might take a bit
more
well we'll see there's a whole uh whole
other two what are you
what are you doing i'm getting my stuff
uh they rat
[ __ ] rats dude what
nothing what did they rat on
oh nothing
[Laughter]
hey it's my reddit oh that's right
sweet oh yeah reddit i yeah i put that
there
um it's like your subreddit or whatever
yeah funny story funny story the uh the
post you saw of me saying yo wanna
collab
yeah complete joke so
i can't believe we're actually here nice
well it worked i expected it was it
really you or
uh it was the user who posted it
yeah no i did okay just checking that
would be weird otherwise
i expected everyone i expected your mods
to just immediately take it down
oh no no they live up all day all this
stuff
that's the rule anything can be posted
well that's threatening
oh sorry yeah it's all filled in so i
don't
oh i fell
be careful yep so there's your subreddit
and then there's obviously more barrels
because of you know the whole thing and
then tambourines oh i didn't even get
that oh nice
yeah yeah and then tambourine tower um
hell yeah it's got it's got all the
pewdiepie classics
and then brofist which i was wondering
yeah i'll be honest
a couple times i've come in here and
i've just been like oh yeah
you betcha oh bro you know
it's i mean it powers you up you know
it's a real it's a real game changer
i can't reach i'm too short you just got
to click man
oh [ __ ]
yeah it's weird bro fisting yourself
is it yeah
are you doing it right now
i mean i i it's up in the air
okay uh so
that's my presentation well done
well done thank you thank you i did this
all this morning i rushed it just like
it's a school presentation
so well i hope i aced it uh
yeah yeah it was fun a little confusing
what was confusing what was confusing um
i still don't get who that is who what
do you mean that's literally me
that's that's just a picture of me yeah
okay
what you don't think that's me
no no i don't know
i can literally send you the picture
it's from i took it this morning while
watching
the good place on netflix is it
is it really yeah it's it's it's me chad
tell me
here i'll send you i'll send you the
picture i'm sending it on discord
it's taken from this picture
well if you send me this oh [ __ ] it is
you yeah it's me
how did how are you thinking but it's so
it's so dark and by
like your hair looks so black
you're a master at selfies i'll i'll
hand that to you thank you
believe it or not i'm also a master at
the best friend challenge
so uh it's not going well so far in that
front
but yeah sure yeah it's okay
usually usually whenever i do collabs
it's like a one-off thing
[Music]
it's all good okay
anyways that's all i had planned well
the other thing i had planned was
we build something on the world together
but we could also just go into your
world i'm up for whatever
i i would love to have the honor of um
building something in this world you
know all right what do you want to build
um i don't know
something swedish could be good
um like a giant giant meatball
you want to build a giant meatball no no
that's awful i don't want to do that
again
gotcha um
oh they really want a meatball how about
it uh
you want to build
uh bridge
ikea bridge an ikea bridge
yeah do you need a bridge somewhere i
i mean i i can use one here
i i like building bridges between people
that's that's that's my thing
oh well you're not good
you know like oh that's a good one okay
okay got it so
i start from one end you start from the
other and then we meet
in the middle nah
i'm not feeling it
[Applause]
all right sure or or
an ikea bridge or or
an ikea meatball all right you're right
hey okay did they serve horses in those
what in the ikea meatballs do they have
horse
in that dude funny story i know that
the family well it's not a funny story
but but i know the family that does
those
never really like that yeah not the
horses but the meatball the distributor
oh yeah the horse meatballs district
yeah and then when it came out i'm like
yeah
how do you know them i don't know
let's go up here let's get some items
usually when i uh when i try to get to
know someone i post on their subreddit
so that's usually my thing is
i got connections yeah yeah i got
horse meats distributors all right are
you gonna give me some stuff
now what happened to the stuff you had
on before
oh yeah you're right
thank you thank you now that's an epic
pewdiepie right there
better right what do you actually want
to build let's let's settle on something
i mean i thought i thought the bridge
metaphor was a nice thing
i only brought up the bridge thing to
dog on you and no
did you really did you no way it didn't
work out very well
you didn't respond and now i feel bad
about it what do you mean i said i can't
rage
you what all right all right you
you pick you pay no no no no
it's only my minecraft world it's your
bill
you're signing the world it's my mind
you know what
it's kind of like this thing right
uh-huh i thought we'd call it
a let's play all right so it's as much
your thing as is mine
all right yeah yeah but i that's all the
ideas i got
so it's on you really how have you made
it this far
[Laughter]
i don't know i hope you know to not take
most of the things i see yeah yeah yeah
same with chat by the way
just so you know no no i'm i'm fine with
chat
no i'm in my chat yeah no that's fine i
don't care about them
i care about what you think thank you
well
we're gonna have to build something
f-bank okay well
what if we built a swedish
fish but they're just
fish i told you bro make a good point
you make a good point
um boo
someone said connect your bra but i
don't think they will look very good
i need a burp um
um yeah i mean you've built meatballs
before
what if we built an ikea
ikeas are kind of big though you know
like they're kind of big yeah i was
gonna propose ikea too that's why i went
ikea bridge
and then we went through this five
minute thing of yes and no yes and no
yeah yeah no i go in the ideas i just
get lost like
i go they make you just gotta follow
that track
i know that's the whole thing is i'm
very bad at following directions oh i
said
like what people tell you to do so i
one time there was this one crazy time
okay check this out
went through all of ikea need to go to
the bathroom
went all the way back through the track
and then couldn't find the bathroom so i
went all the way back to the front
at the night i [ __ ] myself so hard
i don't know just a little story
yep
i don't get it is it real did you
actually [ __ ] yourself
oh no i didn't [ __ ] oh come on
oh okay yes it's a real story thank you
for sharing
this chat really wants a tambourine are
you are you not
no i i'm never tired of tambourines but
i think that that won't look good
because it's circular
you can make circles in minecraft check
this out
check this out look at the floor okay
over here look at this
i thought you were just going to put it
down one block
[Laughter]
look at this yeah just like imagine or
whatever
hey we've been we did the tambourine now
so that's chick
uh how about something how about
something christmas related
oh that is like the time of year oh [ __ ]
what do you want to make what what
what christmas stuff do you believe in
santa
were you uh
i'm in between all right i'll tell you
i tell you what the the the only two
things
that get under my skin yeah more than
anything
so barrels
go on no i was gonna say
santa deniers and racists but
yeah i agree barrels
close third hey hey races are
barrels if you think about it
uh you're gonna have to explain that
just like that that didn't make
anything make more sense
okay how about how about a gingerbread
house then but we do it swedish
style i don't know what that would look
like i don't know just yellow and blue i
don't [ __ ] know at this point carson
i don't know what to do what
did architecture look like all right
that's that's a good
sign uh well technically minecraft is
swedish
so you know everything you look at
right now is swedish architecture
i guess we're done then
uh i mean why are we so indecisive
anything is good come on man yeah but
that's the problem
yeah yeah if you think about it if you
think about it too much
thing then you'll do nothing that's what
i always do okay so
how about we do oh okay that's what you
always do and then we need to break away
from that
that's kind of cool what is that tower
uh it's like this big spiral
why did you make it uh
there was a portal at the top
and
i'm i'm being honest it it was it's a
long story but
um yeah so i mean it just looks cool
when you
fall down that's cool can i try it
i don't think you can get up there
um here let me try to get you up there
um
uh okay and then
what are you doing i heard a black place
and i don't like that
three five don't be so precious come on
uh 120
3662 that is not that was
okay
i'm ready
up the y hey
see it looks cool i feel like i feel
like it should be a surprise at the
bottom kind of like your face or
something
sure there's room for improvement is
that like a happy surprise
i feel like you wouldn't like that
you wouldn't recognize me so
wait how do i play you can put my
picture and you'll say that's just not
you
[Laughter]
yeah you sat your i mean you darkened it
i don't know what to tell you you mean
these barrels oh yeah i need to get out
there you go thanks
[Applause]
does it does it actually bother you what
did i place a blog no no you're fine
okay you ever thought about putting
barrels on merch
barrels i like that or stefano
see you are old school nice
what else you got sometimes yeah that
was just random
i uh yeah i don't even how about a giant
stefano then that'd be cool
we can do a golden one i don't know what
that looks like
i can i can walk you through it
here i'll send you on discord since you
have no idea
all right
oh wait that was wrong stefano sorry
okay that's a
it's a dude from there we go
that'd be cool i can't even i can't even
see that
carson stop being so difficult i'm not
being difficult you're being difficult
what is it you can't see
huh what i can't tell what it is
okay i'll i'll lay a base for it and you
can just use your imagination
on the rest you can work well with
martha well
i thought you captured it well okay
let me let me just let me just go look
at this again
because i i just need to get this fresh
in my mind that you just said that
yeah he said i captured yeah something
something about this it's the eyes
i think it's the eyes that really it
looks like miss pac-man if i'll be
honest with you
take that i don't know i don't know you
know why i do watch
i have watched of yours uh it seems like
every video
that's not true you got all the
references
i just know memes that's that's the
thing uh
especially very like stale ones are you
saying my memes are stale
i don't care you can kill my you can
kill my dog but that's too far man
i just don't see you going around
touting the uh
the fabulous image anymore well that's
the thing i think like
that's been uh ten years
maybe nine years eight years once it
hits 12 years
it'll it'll bounce back that's how means
work
yeah yeah yeah well so every year i try
to get you gun and knuckles to bounce
back so you're saying
that's too soon that's way too soon yeah
i don't know i don't know i mean it's
really like it's worth trying
it's worth a shot here on january 1st
with that tweet
yeah next year is the year the return
have you gone to knuckles
so maybe this year it's gonna if you
keep going
long enough it will happen yeah so
okay so here's here's the actual dilemma
um i'm gonna lay this on you is i don't
have many blocks because it's still a
very
new world um how do you build a museum
then
uh i did you just one plaster someone
else's
museum no so yeah i did build it
but it was on a different world and then
we we oh i say
we brought it in okay so stefano's off
the chart yeah and then because we don't
have a lot of gold and [ __ ]
right yeah okay gotcha um and i would do
creative but that's so
cheating okay and i'm not a cheater
that's good
yeah um so
what if we built
something else okay like an ikea
something i don't know if i have many
blue and
yellow blocks to be honest
we can also build a house out of wood uh
well meeple would be using that because
all we need is dirt
oh you have a lot of stone actually
a stone meatball nah that's so added
no no oh you have a lot of wood i do
have that
a wood meatball there was this one time
why do you save all this stuff what why
do you save all the leaves and [ __ ]
just in case
nice fair enough speaking of eating wood
there was this one time in first grade
where so like our playground had like
this wood chip
floor and somehow i got one wait wood
ship flower i don't get it what do you
what is it instead of like
something safe for children to be
bouncing around in
yeah such as dirt
sand anything besides wood
yeah they had wood chips like little
slices
like chips i'm like i don't get
pieces of wood small pieces of wood ah
so you got a splinter in your knees
no i got a splinter in my teeth
what how i don't know how it got there
it's not like i was going around eating
wood
did you get it out is it there yeah yeah
i got it no it's not still there
okay hopefully i got it out it hurt a
lot that's good and i and i went to the
teacher and i said i think i have
something in my teeth and then they said
that is wood and i said
hmm i thought it was sandwich
it was not sandwiches wood what are you
doing
this is a pun joke i don't get it no no
no there's no joke
this is just i'm just telling you part
of my life here okay
uh that's bill i i don't know
oh this is so cool i'm gonna capture
this moment
can i be in it no it's more of a sign
type of thing
by making a sign
oh sick yeah i know it's
so cool say i told you you know that
all the minecraft
there we go that's better so you just
you just blocked off
oh you're right that's why you did that
it just looks so bad
come on yeah sorry uh okay
so what are we building oh my god
um i genuinely forget i think
i think at this point i'm out of ideas
you got to pick something
no but didn't we come up with something
no i don't think so let's build a
christmas tree it's
christmas happy holidays okay you have a
lot of grass let's do that
what would the grass be used for uh
for the decor you mean the leaves
uh
yeah then leaves dead leaves yes sorry
okay i'm like you're having a bad time
uh
no i'm having such a good time this is
not
[Laughter]
[Music]
super annoying well let's build a
christmas tree carson yeah we
decided all right where do you want to
you know what i'm not asking you any
questions on
hey if it makes you feel any better
you're the worst guest i've had yet
oh really am i the first one yep
i knew it [ __ ] that's a zombie
bro don't say that you hurt my feelings
[Music]
okay i'll just start
i don't know where there's no space
anywhere no
no no you're the least oh wait actually
it's night now this is not good oh we
should sleep
no not like together
no i'm not doing it okay
i'll sleep over here and you call me
difficult
oh it got lying whoa you weren't
you didn't drag it out
[Laughter]
i don't drag anything off no you're
right sorry freaking to the point
yeah you're right oh what's up here okay
come here no
no i'm trying to get things done
are you really do you have the materials
yeah i've got like some leaves posted
discord
come on no come on here we're gonna post
the disc
in this car it'll be shorter than you
climb again what are you expecting me to
do
ability get down here next in front of
the creeper thing
that's a terrible spot no it's a great
spot because i'm not gonna let that
happen oh it's already happening
see this is what happens when you don't
take charge carson
other people do it there you go there's
a base
right that's just leaf no no no no
i have a better idea come on over here
no you don't
this is so hard you don't have oh i'm
gonna die do you have any
do you have any food yeah i do
there you go no thanks you did not pick
that up
come on oh oh i'm sorry am i making it
difficult
are you doing this
am i making this difficult for you yes
stop killing my cows i need those to
reproduce and breed
to reproduce excuse me yes i make them
have sex
oh hell yeah
okay hey do you got any coal just take
the steak man oh i thought it was rotten
me
no it was steak oh okay i thought you
did a carson thing my bad
you've known me for an hour
i've seen it up
spilled the [ __ ] tree
here you go thank you okay uh i say
let's do it over here i figured it out i
figured you had a curse and just gotta
yell
sorry for yelling wait okay okay would
you rather i think doing it on top of
that hill would be cool and that's why i
wanted you to
you do go up there okay you're not gonna
push me out
no because then then you'll just push me
off when you come back
and then we'll be trapped in a and in a
[Music]
yeah a stupid loop yeah you're right i'm
like this listen i've known you foreign
anyways i'm sorry i'll take it back
i apologize would you say nothing
all right i'm going up i don't want to
be the
what do you call me the worst guest i'm
going i mean
you're the worst guest but you're the
first guest as well
but you built out the sun yeah but no
one else has been on the world
i'm confused what
okay well let's just say
there's room for improvement my chat is
saying both of you need to be more
assertive what
oh really oh really
i think a problem yeah yeah
wait that's not a startup
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you're right [ __ ] up chat we know
what we're doing
stop being backseat i know what i'm
doing mm-hmm
what if we take one of these jungle
trees and then we
we make it into a christmas tree what
are you doing
i just made it so i don't fall oh see
those are still gonna keep the kang
so the king
oh wait no no oh no no they won't
because you built them
that's a king no decaying
they can't oh decaying okay gotcha yeah
yeah
i'm american i have a stupid accent
okay so let's what if we made this tree
into a christmas tree
yeah but we only have the leaves
do you think it would work i can get us
other materials
okay huh
i'll get him
how long do you have um about five
minutes
no see what but like actually i don't
know
i usually stream for like two hours
oh [ __ ] we gotta hurry up no please
yeah yeah that's a good idea on the real
do you
so i know you want to do a thing as well
no i'm happy to just build something
yeah yeah okay
yeah okay uh
okay first off we got to get these vines
off this tree
do we really no no no no they can be
there
dude okay
i can't come down now how do i be a very
pretty tree
no but then it looks more voluminous
right
oh yeah okay uh
okay okay okay i don't want to get rid
you know what
you know what carson i don't realize it
already looks like a tree
it does it does but we can make it a
christmas tree with like ornaments
and stuff uh
okay yeah so
okay i'll let you take charge because we
you know
it's your show you should be assertive
and you are you've been so far i mean
who's the big man here that's you
i'm the big man i've seen point i've
seen your selfies
it shows you didn't know it was me
well i know now i looked at i looked at
them and i thought big man
right there big man big man all right
that's fair that's fair
okay uh i'm just getting rid of the
trees around this right now dude
the apples look like um christmas
ornaments
um can you hang them
no but i mean yeah
are you getting rid of the other trees
my opinion they look like damn
apples all right cute sorry
how dare you yeah
all right am i cutting down the other
ones you can call me carson that's
uh yeah no don't cut down that one
probably not why not um uh well you can
yeah go for it you're not being
assertive which one is it
well i was just thinking that one could
stay because we mostly just need to get
rid of the base for this one so that we
could see
what's going on with this tree and
actually hang ornaments and stuff
okay also i'm gonna make the top fuller
i think
or
well i'm gonna i'm gonna put some rings
on this [ __ ] you know like
christmas trees have like do you do
christmas in sweden
like yeah okay so
what do the trees look like there um
they're a little uh thinner i would say
not so voluminous
are you looking for a thin tree or
why why are they thinner i don't know
altitude uh yeah you're right we are
much higher up climate
okay is there anything i can help you
with i feel like i'm not doing anything
uh just keep getting rid of the leaves
down there
but don't we need them like a base
this is your build you take lead
all right carson listen here's what
we're gonna do
we're gonna build the best goddamn tree
you've ever seen
okay no no no no no no no no no no this
is my plan
all right okay yeah yeah my plan
you can't you can't just go in that that
was my plane
that's like that's like someone making a
joke and then the other person says it
too
that doesn't work right yeah okay the
leaves at the bottom stays they stay
they stay they stayed
you're doing it stop so sorry stop i
didn't realize
okay we're going to start with the
bottom layer connected to these
is that a problem no no
no it's not no no no no not working
i'm sorry okay
we'll build one layer here right pretty
large
yeah and then we go up build another
layer circle
a little smaller okay and one layer up
same thing a little smaller all right
you did a circle before so i know you
can do circles yeah i was like
i was like you don't have to do it again
i'm just so good at it i know you have a
talent
but put it to use for this bill all
right i'm just gonna start building
okay yeah so
yeah our things
uh yeah good
how are your things it's been all right
yeah you sound a little down uh no
no it's just
i had this like stream that i had
planned and it's just it didn't
it didn't not
what do you what do you mean nothing no
don't worry about it
dude are you talking about this stream
this is going great
yeah this is going great well see this
is why you don't plan stuff like i think
because then
you can't go wrong okay i just get
anything no you're right you didn't uh
all right let's build a
a little bigger on the base
all right see now it's just forming
naturally
it's taking place yeah it's like a
christmas tree
i'm not gonna count or anything we'll
just go by feel you know
because that's what christmas is it's
all about feelings
tell me some feelings
i don't think anyone has ever said that
to me
never gone to therapy what does that
mean tell me some feelings
throw me some thoughts
what are what are you thinking i'm
thinking we should build this
and work together that's what i'm
working on so we can have a nice
wholesome reddit moment and be like look
what they built
this is so cool
i go on the specific like like they have
like the lounge you know the lounge
subreddit no i don't i don't know what
that is the only person typing on there
and it feels great
what is the lounge i don't they've got
this like lounge place just for
reddit gold people the the people that
pay money
and it's like wait you can pay for ready
i'm so confused
is it yeah yeah yeah is it because you
got gold or because you paid for gold
because that that makes a difference
right i think you can give yourself gold
probably
oh okay that's lame then you'd
probably i mean okay i get it from other
people
so i mean i'm fine okay good
but
[Music]
all right tell me about your feelings
no no it's tell me some feelings
not about no i i changed it yeah oh you
changed it up
i because i wanted you to start saying
happy
what sad those are emotions
it's difficult okay well okay
tell me the difference between emotions
and feelings oh no i don't
know now i won't okay
all right moving on to the next [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm gonna die again
hold up what do you think are we ready
for the next layer this is circular for
you
should we go miserable
well we knew it was gonna be miserable
come on oh no it's awesome i love it
yeah there you go
there you go yeah let's do that okay um
yeah there we go okay yeah yeah next
level yeah
um oh well look at you
yep
all right how much do you um
nothing no nothing never mind
well i it was going to sound rude so i
don't want to say it but
no no i literally don't care okay well
ask me how much i talk to people no
should i ask you that i would say not
much
it's good same for me so that works out
okay well i just
wonder how much you get done today
because like we have such a rapid speed
here then
i just think how much do i get you're
like one of those
super um what's it called when you're
really fast at doing stuff
uh
uh [ __ ] what is it called productive
people no
no you know you say okay i spent all
night last night watching the good place
on netflix
nice do you like it
i cried you're crying really yeah i i
had some feelings right there and there
we go yeah look at that
funny story they say your name on that
[ __ ] yeah i know
i don't am i i don't remember what it
was but i think i'm in the bad place
yeah you are uh well no i think
i think they brought you up as someone
that
should go to the bad place okay so i'm
not technically in it that's fine then
right cool do you think i should be in
the bad place
no no here's the thing here's the thing
is the whole
is the whole like crux of the show right
is
uh they need to figure out
spoiler alert for anyone that hasn't
spoil it
uh they gotta figure out
a better system for how people and
ethics is
then yeah yeah and
you are brought up in in the context of
people that could be just randomly
selected out of a hat to go through the
bad place is is
basically what it selected out of a hat
well no it was you were just the name uh
that's like name dropped uh it was cool
because i was like i'm gonna talk to
that guy tomorrow oh really
so you watch that episode specifically
yeah
hey well if you think about it
there's no good or bad it's just
thinking that makes them
so so if anything it makes no sense to
have a good and a bad place
wouldn't you agree
okay i'm gonna need to roll that one
back for a second
a lot to take in there
yes i see what you're saying okay cool
that
good and bad is completely human
construct
in the first place that's right you're
right
so the whole show really
is built around
ethics and philosophy but really it's
completely pointless
yes well that's that's the thing is the
whole
the whole show you know it's filtered
you watch the show
i i watch season one yeah hey you know
what's a bad place
what do you know what's a bad place
sweden
yeah probably this right here this right
here
this is not a good place carson what our
tree
is very disappointing no it's awesome
i can't i can't i can't see how
if i'm making it smaller we need another
um
i'm going to do an endurance because
that's all i have to work with here
you're doing what in dirt uh this
the stem of the tree
the stem the shaft i don't know
oh
would you like some wood you're just
going
i'm being assertive carson let me let me
do that now you're doing it thank you oh
the trunk sorry
chat corrected me i apologize for my
lack of
vocabulary
i don't even know what it's calling yeah
i guess i know swedish yeah
what's your favorite language uh
um i don't know
like do you think any language sounds
prettier in in general than another um
yeah yeah i think so but i don't know if
there's one that's like oh that's so
beautiful but
there's ugly languages but i don't want
to say that yeah and people think it's
just an ugly language
no franciscan you you think so i think
it sounds
disgusting coming out and that and
german
uh there's there's just so much there's
so much
in those languages i don't know
does german really i think it's dutch
that has more
over there right am i wrong
i'm curious i don't know i shouldn't be
speaking if i don't know
uh hit me up with another trunk up here
carson
a trunk and another trunk bro yeah i got
you
hold up let me know danish is really
ugly i stand by that
oh yeah yeah it sounds awful
i think even danish people know anymore
see i don't i don't know your vision
here
thank you yeah okay so this will be the
tippy top right or how tall
we're building up to you man
i don't know this is your thing oh oh
look at that
it's one block now right make sense
right
not even
i don't know i don't know should we put
a star on top
yeah we could do that i gotta okay you
do this sir
hey could you put some block i can jump
up to so i don't die
uh where oh god
i don't know anyway um
i'm all right there
can you make that there's i can't water
i can't see
i can't see now you're oh no
oh you're probably not i'm just gonna
risk it there you go oh
okay oh i like that look look at that
that's great
uh i feel like this is the time i need
to back up
you know look at what we made so we can
analyze
well i already know it's going to be
awesome so here okay well
i appreciate your confidence yeah i
don't mean it i don't share it right now
wait where's the
what were they called the thing that
hang down that you can climb on
vines vines that's right did you just
jump down
yeah i did okay use glowstone to make a
star oh i like that
that's a good idea we'd have to go to
another though let's do it
um no oh
i guess we won't then
oh it looks so good what other uh
okay where are you sorry i can't i'm
actually
curious where do you go
atp me no i'm going to put you in
spectator real quick oh thanks bro
wow yeah i know right okay
so i would say okay
um
it could it could use some extra love
let's put it that way
happy holidays no no it's not done don't
say it yet
okay um where does it need a little
extra love
everywhere yeah
you know i wouldn't like it i would make
the base
episode charlie you remember the charlie
brown christmas but
no i haven't seen that oh
wait charlie brown yeah yeah i've seen
it sorry yeah yeah you have a really
shitty tree
are you saying our tree is [ __ ] come on
man yeah come on man
that's exactly what i'm saying um
um okay i will go get glowstone while
you
work on this i'll perfect it okay so
this layer is
it's too small and then that layer is
too big
gotcha um are you
somewhere where you won't die sorry how
do i yeah i think i'm okay
no wait i don't what do you mean why
would i fall
because i'm gonna put you back into
survival mode do it
oh that's how that works yeah
all right best of luck you're going to
the netherlands
yeah but wait wait wait wait i have a
better idea
okay why don't we use cocoa beans as a
star
because there's a lot of them and they
kind of look like glowy
things you know being creative how's
that gonna work
i don't know it just it's just an idea
all right so they hang off
all right you're right it's shitty my
bang
do you just not like the nether uh
well you're the one going yeah
if you insist
all right hey
i'm just trying to get you out of it i
do
also have 39 blocks of gold oh really
we could have filmed a stephanos a
little baby one
oh what if that's the star
stephano yeah let's do it okay nice
see now we're working together this is
great i was working
just fine the entire time
sorry
i'm going to get a variety of items
should i should i come with you to the
nether if you're going to the nether
no i'm not okay good we're just gonna
okay good
what's your deal i don't wanna go
you don't have to i'm not making you
it's okay all right everything's okay
okay we're good we're good
do you wanna do you wanna try i think
here's the question
when you're in a creative project you
either
you come to a point where you just
acknowledge that is [ __ ]
and just be like haha look at this
shitty thing i made or
you still try and make it pretty and you
own that [ __ ]
which one are you feeling i kind of like
how it is i don't think it's beyond
repair okay okay that sounds good to me
especially since i think our ornaments
are going to be made out of
hay bales and packed ice oh
that's the thing it's a humble tree
and we'll call it huge humble freak
nah pewts and carson because we build it
together come on
you should put a sign for that as well
you're doing that oh you know i'm on it
okay good what okay
crazy idea what if we made an ornament
out of wood
oh yeah yeah yeah okay
like uh it's like symbolic for what
it's like a tree and there's wood on it
what the hell
that's like awesome that's symbolic i
gotcha
okay it's symbolic of it being a tree
you mean a little ironic could you say
lantern
would it be ironic a wood made out of
wood
that's weird
this is thinking beyond that's this is
being creative i like that
yeah what was i doing
um you were getting gold and yeah
straight up man
oh it's gonna be sick lanterns
if people ask hey what's that tree made
out of we can just say
wood
[Music]
no it's grass come on
is that something you do often i i often
say
wrong things yeah i think we've done
i've done a couple already
it's sweet sweden me i can't help it oh
i appreciate you not making fun of me
for it what's wrong with sweden
nothing we got and everything
it is yeah but you know the swedish flag
is actually
blue and yellow representing the sun
and the ocean isn't that way cooler
i'd say it's way cooler okay what does
red represent
redstone yeah i knew you'd say that
well that's actually cooler [ __ ]
well it's just gonna have to work
hey what does the american flag
represent huh
i don't know there you go you got star
so that's cool
we did like this pledge that they made
you you okay so in your country did they
make you say a pledge everything no
and i always thought that was super
brain watchy and weird
it is weird yeah totally weird did you
do that
yeah i had to because i was a child
school in america i'm trying to think
what they were trying to make us
do i pledge to elite i pledge my
allegiance to the flag
blah blah blah every day and i was like
what the [ __ ]
look like i got older i was like what's
that what am i
saying and yeah it was every day
and then and then the teachers were like
what year did you get woke
do this match and then i was like what
the hell
as if i do that math and then i did the
math because i had to
did you ever do math
yes yes i did that i just yeah
you're like mad you like math
it's more fun than memorizing stuff what
are you memorizing
like history and i don't know
and languages you have to memorize
but don't you like languages well i
don't like memorizing stuff i'm very bad
at it
oh
clearly i can't remember what a single
thing is called
what's something you have memorized i
had nothing
just brain empty i guess you have those
mean ones the
the cell of the me what is it that you
teach in america
mitochondria so i don't know what it's
called i was called in english
oh mitochondria yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's awesome i do remember that
and finally everyone remembers that one
don't know why but yep that's that's in
my head
for some reason does this work
i need chains i need chains
oh to hang it off of yeah i need chains
to hang back to the nether
why don't you can we get a lot of
torches actually because that would look
good right
well that's i got the lanterns oh you
got liners
sweet how many you got
multiple 27. sweet that would look great
see that's the thing with lights that'll
make anything
look good unless faces
if you're ugly
you call me ugly i've seen your selfies
so no okay good
[Music]
[ __ ] i'm i didn't know where that was
going for a second
i was like dude you're beautiful come on
look like a minecraft player let's just
say that that's
not a compliment is it not hey you look
like a minecraft player mister
i revived minecraft
is that my nickname now according to me
nice i'm a nicknamer
guy i think i i reference you as a
a guy you look like
you look like um really
really cool
[Music]
that was so kind you're welcome
i'm pulling these lanterns down nice
oh people say you look like peter
griffin i can kind of see that
isn't peter griffin fat
you're more wide i would say
you think i'm wide well you have that um
do you work out do you lift no see if
you did
you look swole as hell dude you got that
body type
i've been checking you out yeah
you could be worked out yeah yeah you'll
feel good i got these
i got these dumbbells hell yeah do you
really
yeah i ordered them off of amazon which
type
like uh uh
like dumb
[Music]
okay and
i haven't gotten them out of the box yet
oh no
but i will you should
okay ah i'm fine
hey what's up hey okay you lit up
sweet see this looks better already i
did light up
um i have a question
we've only done these circles right
should we connect them somehow do you
reckon
how would we do that uh just like build
kind of diagonally upwards
like stairs
what do you mean to like get between
them
i don't what i don't know what you're
saying
i don't know either like okay i'll show
you
okay we can delete this if this is bad
but kind of like oh wait sorry
and oh [ __ ] i'm already
like like that but that would be a lot
of work but you know
at least it will be connected right you
know what i mean
so we keep doing that around i'm gonna
have to do everywhere
uh
use vines to connect i said do we have
vines
yep should we do that then it might be
easier
do your trees connect
where they look it's all about how it
looks right
wait actually i i think that would
actually look cool
if you did it like that
how you just had it yeah but there would
be so much to do it on all of them
i mean i'm up for it but i think i think
vines i think we should do vines
if you have vines does that that makes
sense to me i don't have vaunt
[Laughter]
all right well i will pick one layer
each
hey nice you're a sharp shooter
thanks man you want to play minecraft
sometime
thank you for doing this it's all good
man
it's fun
i just like building yeah
you don't i love it okay
i believe they no i actually i mean
that's the whole point of the series
okay one building nice that's my whole
thing
i can tell something now
i had questions for you that i just have
i forgot
so oh you forgot them
yeah i mean you got uh what's my least
favorite language
or was it favorite that was that random
oh let's see that was impromptu
okay that was improv i'm a little improv
guy
um questions for you
no
no no i don't sorry you don't want
i don't have any questions sorry oh
no i i wasn't asking you for questions
okay uh i tried
how old are you how about that you said
you were seven when you watched me sir
twelve now fourteen fifteen
twenty one what yeah
damn bro how old did you think if i
actually thought it would guess like
yeah maybe 1920. really yeah
[Laughter]
no i'm like an adult or whatever you're
in and out
look at you how old are you
bro i'm [ __ ] 30 dude what's that like
my sister's 30. not really so yeah yeah
so
i mean i have some experience talking to
people you know
you know like senior citizens itself
it's good i like it
really yeah you don't feel like you've
hit a turning point in your life and
things are about to go downhill
yeah that's usually the insinuation when
hitting third isn't it
no i mean that's that's how i feel every
single year so oh
okay dude this is a
high point we're playing minecraft
pewdiepie carson yeah
this would be highlight i'm 31 actually
my chat just reminded me i'm hella
[ __ ] dumb holy [ __ ]
see i've never talked to a 31 year old
so this is different ah
that changes things i see yeah yeah wait
where did you do it
oh fines huh what do you say to me
where where right
uh like right like irl
or well we start with my crime
i am in my home getting leaves and vines
okay nice nice
yeah this year just flew by didn't he
i'm sorry i burped again that's really
gross that's all right i do it all the
time
really yes oh man oh yeah we got
something in common
thanks man i'm glad i could come on in
the show
okay i've i i this made me think of
something
okay so you're you're like a big
youtuber and i think there's been a lot
of moments in your
in your career where you don't have to
be
like at least a little bit humble in
in a lot of cases but i think like what
i could not tell you
[Laughter]
seems like i'm not bad but you seem very
self-aware of
of where you are and you're the number
one youtuber i don't know
well that's the thing i don't think i am
so
okay but you okay okay just sorry
just say the question yeah i wouldn't i
wanted to know if
okay you get if you get tired of people
saying like you're so real or you're so
humble
uh i feel like i don't hear that much
anymore so maybe
maybe that i'm not anyway
i'm putting an orange are you getting
tired of it
am i getting tired of oh you're like oh
this [ __ ] pewdiepie
yeah oh it's not that humble oh about
you no
uh no yeah yeah it's like a little
ornament
all right see you got some building
skills there
yeah um no i i ask because
what do people usually say about you
that's that's the thing is
is you know i i try to
to i try my best to be like humble or
down to earth or whatever but
it's very weird to be
told that constantly
that i'm down to earth or humble just
because i'm
quote-unquote in the spotlight or
anything like that right
so i wanted i wanted to know if like it
was any different for you
or yeah or your perspective on that
no i think i'm just swedish i don't
think i am humble
it's just uh we're switching people
aren't allowed to brag about stuff we
call it
it's like a social rule it's called
yante logan
you're not you know i don't know what
that meant it just me
it's like this unspoken rule as a
swedish person you're not allowed to
quote on quote flex okay yeah
what happens if you do fly all right you
get you out loud
and you start showing off your hot gamer
body yeah the swedes don't vibe today
they don't buy with that well what's the
big deal
i don't know and people online wouldn't
call them humble you know
that's true that's true that's a fair
point
hey could you hand me some binds i feel
like i haven't done anything now in a
while
all right i'm legitimately out
i just use them all and i think i don't
all right plan b
plan b
well dude i just had another question
that i was going to ask you
okay i don't remember what it was now
cool must have not been important uh
see i never i people always say that but
i never feel like that's true
i always forget important stuff it's
[ __ ]
it's funny my lawyer out of all people
always say that
i feel like they are the ones that
definitely
should remember am i right what did you
say
no it's not important it probably i
forgot
am i boring you carson no i just i'm
terrible at listening dude me too that's
all right
i space out all the time i made a
star oh you did nice
yeah okay
i'll keep the the final product
sort of fresh
i won't look at it that's what i'm
saying
did you space out again what's going on
yeah i did you're putting a lot of focus
aren't you
i appreciate that no i i had questions
and i'm trying to think of them
do you feel obligated to ask questions
we can just play minecraft
conversation starters and also i've
wanted to talk to you since i was like
12. since you saw fabulous
since i saw that fabulous big girl like
damn damn one day i wanna i wanna talk
to that guy
yeah no you just genuinely just like
been in the game so long and it's like
too long man too long yeah
you almost ready to get out nah
no no i'm on my peak right now right
here
good one that's funny you have some
zingers sometimes
it wasn't it wasn't meant to be a singer
oh
it was genuine
am i making it worse am i making it
worse you're good you're good take the
leaves
okay i feel like i'm making it worse but
i think i'm doing what
i said where it's like you know what at
this point i don't think it matters
[Laughter]
no it's gonna be dope it's gonna be a
dope ass okay i appreciate i appreciate
your positive attitude but let's not
i can't pull anyone here all right this
[ __ ]
oh you don't have twitter oh that's
right you don't use twitter is it
because it sucks
do you like twitter no yeah i hate it
it's the [ __ ] worst i absolutely
would
not have it if it weren't for it being a
part of my business
yeah see i said that for so long and
then i'm like you know what i [ __ ]
hate it doesn't matter
yeah see that's what happens when you're
30 cars
you're also pewdiepie so you can get
away with that what kind of business do
you get on twitter let's get real here
huh
uh i follow like 2400 people
so like and then i have dms open for
people that i
follow so i feel obligated to keep it
running so that those people can stay in
contact with me if they need to get in
contact with me
but why why do you feel obligated
because what if everything goes downhill
then everything ends well
i don't think it will dude you're
calling me carson you're minecraft god
come on
you're good
i feel you that doesn't make any sense i
feel you though i know what you mean
i'm not trying to press you or anything
well consider me press well i don't know
i just feel like everyone has that
idea in their head that it's so much
worse to be without than what it really
is
right i don't think it's that bad
you'll be fine but hey if you want to
keep it
that's that's all good to me i i'm just
getting to where i just say stupid [ __ ]
on there and then
say it yeah i know i laid it off my
phone a week ago oh nice
that's part of why it was like topical
for me yeah like
yeah i i'm legitimately not even
i just what's up maybe like 30 minutes
in the past week
that's good what's the tweet you regret
well well if you really want to know
i don't know if you don't want to know
when you phrase it like that
well there have been some things in my
time on twitter
when i was stupid and um
you know that's not like a bad joke or
something we're gonna have to get into
it
no no no yeah no it was just i got you
we've all done that
yeah we've all been there you
this is why i don't have it i know i
know i can't handle it
that's fair that's fair also you [ __ ]
this up i think
plus twitter put is overtaken by
k-pop stance and it's just not fun
anymore they ruined it
well actually now it's minecraft stance
is it really no i didn't know
yeah yeah yeah um
every single day uh i've been dissing
the minecraft community this whole time
oh god oh that's good no you're fine no
no that's
just the minecraft community because
they suck
anyways uh no every single day there's
uh there's a creator from
from have you heard of dream smp see i
was
i don't know what smp is i i know dream
but i don't know
survival multiplayer oh gotcha yeah yeah
um but it's it's basically just
server with lots of youtubers oh okay
this is what it comes down to
um and there's drama so there's oh no no
it's not even drama
it's it's uh it's just the creators are
so popular on on twitter on there
that uh they get trending every day oh
that's cool
[Laughter]
it is thanks thanks for sharing man
they uh i i think one one i saw
was creator uh
and then it said the creator name built
a house on on dream smp today and it was
trending on twitter
in america which is
fun i don't get it they build a house
oh in minecraft cool
cool it is cool isn't it
it's fun it's a fun little thing so are
you
are you trending no oh man that sucks
no yeah well i i'm cool with it
yeah yeah no i'm i'm i'm it's just fine
with me
okay are you trending
uh i think once when i played with
corpse i think that was the last time oh
that's big that's big yeah yeah yeah i
played the course the other day i tried
to get these nuts trending didn't happen
ah yeah i know do you think we can make
a trend now we're playing minecraft
no no not even worth a shot
these nuts
oh man dude i remember actually first
time we played
you could span my chat with the [ __ ] and
balls and i guess
genuinely really annoyed and then i felt
really bad afterwards
oh i don't think i would have done that
okay so with someone else
no no i probably no it's probably my
fans
but okay i don't think i spammed your
chat with me okay so then i yell at your
chat i know exactly what oh i know what
you're talking about
yeah yeah explain explain this no it
wasn't fine it was super annoying
no no yeah okay
so are you talking about like in
minecraft chat uh
no oh they just came to my stream chat
and started spamming cotton balls i'm
like
shut the [ __ ] up please okay all right
cool
i have enough sense not to like send
people to spam [ __ ] i'm glad we
addressed this
but if it was in your minecraft chat
then it was definitely me
okay maybe what
maybe it was i don't know that would be
funny
yeah i so i had this bit
where i would ask random people if they
like dick and balls
oh dick bacon ball okay yeah
um it's a bit redundant question isn't
it
yeah it's it it was supposed to be funny
because
we were saying taking balls
i get it i get it i make peepee poopoo
jokes
it's all good
a little disappointed that wasn't in the
museum but we can add that
yeah right um
[Laughter]
what you you make it seem like it's not
gonna make it cut that woody
i mean just leave the museums to me
that's all that's all i'm saying
all right um but yeah no it was a it was
super funny and everyone loved it it was
super funny and everyone laughed
and and then everyone clapped when
everyone said
dick and balls yeah yeah okay
but i also remember uh you
kept saying my name weird and then do i
say it wrong
or is it like more like
uh stand up guy is that what you got
carson more like fartson yeah
yeah you've been expecting that one yeah
i don't know
if anything's just right back it feels
like nothing's changed
oh no yeah no i but yeah that was
that was our first interaction with each
other wasn't it
oh shoot i don't i don't remember
but yeah yeah
okay what else are you doing today
what else going to bed watching good
place
no i finished that i cried oh so wait so
this
it's all over like it's finished now
yeah yeah yeah okay
we gotta watch it then wait
this is actually coming together is it
really
i don't believe it i don't believe it
yeah no it's coming together it looks
like a tree
oh yeah well it definitely is a tree
i i kind of i kind of sort of built in
your ornaments i didn't
realize until i did it that's fine
yeah the worst part is definitely the
base
all right okay well that's easy to fix
then right no
no probably not
okay
oh i don't know where the gas is coming
from but it's just
in me and it's like ah what's the deal
with body
what did you eat eat something weird no
i had like
breakfast what are you for breakfast
what do you eat for breakfast that's a
more interesting question yeah is it
really
dude same breakfast everything porridge
it's great for your stomach you won't
have any problem
and it fills you up what kind of
porridge
ah there's different flavor ones it's uh
there's syrup porridge like
chocolate porridge there's salted
caramel porridge
what is porridge what's in it what's the
consistency like
uh it depends how much water you add to
it
kind of you know it is kind of gross
kind of mushy and weird but it tastes
delish
great breakfast won't have any issues
then if you really want to if you really
want to be easy on your stomach you
should actually drink some lemon
lemon water i hear that's good
so glad we're having this conversation
by the way
i don't know there's nothing wrong
okay good good yeah i can't i can't tell
but that's good that's reassuring it's
hard to gauge
no no
you're an open book carson i don't know
if that's any better
in the best way possible yeah am i
off-putting lemon water kills your teeth
uh chat says don't do that
sorry kiss your teeth
don't do that i wasn't going to okay
just a little bit off
sorry i'm am i off-putting
oh like i thought you said am i awesome
because yes off-putting now well thank
you
i'm gross too it's all right
i didn't
[Laughter]
that's usually implied with off-putting
isn't it
no no okay you're going for something
going for something else what were you
thinking
uh
like do i make you
uncomfortable or not know how to respond
in any
situations i'd say maybe an hour ago yes
but
not right now no uh
yeah it's the oven
i told you bro it's the other one in the
oven
i like that throwback very nice yeah i
remember things sometimes
nice throwback joke i like it
i'm running low on um leaves here
you don't mind doing the last layer i
don't think so
take those thanks man i'll get you more
okay is it does it look bad that we
built in the christmas ornaments
nope i like it you sure
yep no genuinely i think it's cool okay
good
it's kind of like they're in like
actually in the tree
you know okay uh [ __ ] i need more leaves
were you getting more leaves yes that's
yeah
on it sweet on it sweet i'll just um
hey can you put me in spectator mode
then yeah
this is not good there are so many
creepers
oh [ __ ] it's yeah it's too cloudy i
can't really see
oh you gotta turn off the clouds then oh
you have the mom
yeah uh
where are they
um
yeah sure
what yeah you can tell what that is if
you just finish the base
we'll be all right it looks good i'm
honestly surprised by how good it's
gonna look
okay if we lit it up i think it would
look better like putting a bunch of
torches in
it okay you can take me out of spectator
please
thank you jump
nice
take these all right
since we talked about uh h and stuff
before
when you're 31 what do you want to do
where do you want to be this is a job
interview now
oh this actually reminds me of one of my
questions yeah
uh yeah so you gotta respond to mine
first
yeah i will okay just
if i forget i'll bring it
okay nice okay uh okay
um when i'm 31 i have no [ __ ] clue
i here's the thing is i don't think i
can just be a youtuber
forever no see i i used to think that
too
and here here i am carson
i think i think you were also dealt a
unique hand you know
i don't know you don't think so
maybe i don't know
see i actually you know it would be
easier to continue
doing exactly what you're doing yeah
yeah a lot of people fall into that trap
but sorry and change right okay go ahead
and be successful like you are
like i think it's easier to keep going
with it is it not
well you know i actually tried you felt
that pressure when i was younger
like a little older than your age i i
felt like oh [ __ ] i'm not gonna be able
to do youtube
so i started doing a bunch of projects
and stuff that i didn't really
find fun or interesting and then i just
ended up realizing
this sucks this is not what i wanted i
just
played into like this uh
idea that oh you have to do something
else otherwise you're not you're if
you're just a youtuber that can't be
enough
right i don't i don't think that's
necessarily the case anymore
dude so i wouldn't i wouldn't put too
much pressure on that
right but i still see what you mean it's
a valid valid concern
i think part of it for me comes down to
like how fulfilling it is
right i'm i'm right sure i'm still
having a constant
deal like you're not saying this is
fulfilling for you
building i don't i don't know why i'm
doing it
i don't think anyone nice it's good
money
and i will i was a kid you know
yeah right um
but i don't know i
when i'm 31 i i can't help but think to
myself i want to be
like making something that lasts longer
than
that's cool because youtube videos
it's a quick thing isn't it yeah they're
not going to last
longer than a year most times yeah yeah
yeah
that's a good plan i mean people will
remember them
but i don't think a lot of people are
complaining left an impact
on you at least what's an impact but i
don't think people are still watching
them
like you would like all right i don't
know i can see that
like avatar the last airbender is
like i'm getting old now and people are
still watching stuff like that
constantly you know still
super popular in pop culture so what
were you thinking
uh sorry no go ahead well what were you
thinking like you would do
like a game or is there anything
interesting
yeah okay that's a good thing that's a
good example though i mean
you don't just do youtube you're you're
all over the place with what you do
and i think i mean correct me if i'm
wrong isn't that partly because of
the fulfillment of it
hopefully like creative fulfillment or
like well are you like i don't know
i don't know me i mean most of my focus
is on youtube so even if i do other
projects
i feel like i can't really put all my
all into it a lot of times which can be
frustrating
you know so it's like the tsuki market
is is that
that's more of a fun thing i can do with
my wife so it's like
that's cool okay but it's not it doesn't
i don't wake up and
like what's next yeah
do you have any more leaves nope okay
we're done there
okay we can get one we're done no no no
maybe
maybe a little bit more i would say i
would say we need
more leaves and more um
lanterns but i don't know where you lit
up did you lay up each floor
no i didn't i can i can do more though
okay nice
let me get more leaves real quick
remember when you asked me why i keep
the leaves around
you knew i said just in case and you
know what
yeah but we could have built anything
else
you know what okay all right i'll give
it to you i'll get it that was right
you were right i was right absolutely
i'm on top carson's right you're on top
yeah here you go i got you more leaves i
found them
thank you oh a lot more
sweet how do we get in i don't think i
technically need them anymore but
oh you have them okay correct
so how long have you been doing youtube
um
i've had my channel for like eight years
okay um
but i i think i've only seen your stuff
since like
around that minecraft stream
yeah that i i've started blowing up
until like 2018
and actually like making a job or
anything nice um
and then like obviously last year with
the minecraft stuff helped a lot
yeah yeah but yeah i i
started making stuff when i was like
like i made the my youtube channel the
day i turned 13 because i
i uh i couldn't go against youtube law
and make an account before i was the age
of 13. oh that's right
well some people get their parents to do
it yeah of course
um but i made it that day and i was
making believe it or not minecraft
videos so
nice i believe it i believe it
you did a good job on the bottom that
looks good you got the chains and
everything oh yeah
chat what do you think we're missing
this thing is awesome
[Laughter]
you want you won't burn it up or
anything you're going to keep it oh
no of course i'm keeping it no this is
fantastic
i love it nice oh it's fantastic i
actually i'm glad
i actually love this one so maybe i'm
the best guest now
yo yeah you are yeah yeah yeah that's
the in the board
the oven is working man the oven is
lighting up dude we are
looking at three lava oh people say
presents under the tree that might make
sense right
i don't know it makes sense but do i
have them
you can put like one gold block one red
block just simple
that's so true i have those on me as
well
oh you can oh sorry it's cool
say so much nicer when you're not
killing someone's dog is
it i didn't do that
that wasn't even your dog it was
technically mine oh i see
you just named this event as well
colored colored wood
oh colors we ain't got that no
sorry chad is chad is backseating
they're not helping
i did ask them for advice
they said colored wool oh
don't have that yeah we don't have that
if i had that it'd be awesome it'd be
sick
we'll have to settle for very good
oh netherstar wait you have those right
no no i don't
i don't have that i have this piece of
grass
check this out
brass or what do you say grass
thanks i was i was clearing them up
this what is this like shoes
it's a present i didn't have enough
blocks
no no no oh that's cool actually sorry
but why don't we
when we just do like that then like a 2d
one
is that weird and then we can build like
sorry i took your sorry then we can
build like what
that doesn't do anything
oh
like little tiny presents
that's so boom yeah
what are you what are you hoping for uh
as a christmas kid
uh christmas gifts are weird now
um how sad
because i'm a youtuber
and we make too much money you just buy
whatever you want
i don't buy much yeah but if something
is very attainable
because it's because you're so humble
carson okay stop
that's the thing is i hate that i'm
sorry i
can't say that i hate that because it's
like what what do you respond with
yes i am thank you for noticing
you're not right you're so right
you just come across like an [ __ ]
yeah you're right it's setting you up to
sound like an [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's a good point never
thought of that
but like people say it all the time and
i'm like
it's it's whatever i'll get over it yeah
you need like a good go-to answer
like what like uh what's something
really
mean i can say in response to you're so
humble
yeah finally [ __ ]
seemed like you had something something
else going on there
all right
hey dude we're on the same page here
[ __ ] yeah get rid of that [ __ ]
i just kind of saw what you were doing
and nice
yeah you kind of took the lead you were
assertive
uh i think we're both gonna start over
here today that's true
yeah do you like anime yeah i'm talking
to ask you about anime and i talk about
anime a lot
do you really yeah i love anime and i
also
i watch like all the anime youtubers
like uh
do you ever watch like uh i don't know
many to be honest
i don't only know joey yeah well he's
he's on
connor yeah yeah the trash today's
podcast
all those guys yeah i watched their
podcasts and stuff oh nice
yeah i listened to a lot of episodes
actually but i haven't in a while
i need to catch up
uh what's your favorite anime
i i don't know i watched uh i'm watching
great pretender right now it's really
good
it's on netflix
[Laughter]
it's got really good art style it's very
unique
and you never know what's gonna happen
next it just keeps changing it's a wild
ride and you're on it
bro i don't care do they have
swords i don't think they do
yeah i think i bet they don't
i'm kidding i honestly my favorite
genre is slice of lifestyle i have no oh
no
slice of life what the [ __ ]
i'm a boring guy oh
bro you dating anyone no oh there you go
that's why you're like slice of life
what's your problem
you need to fill that hole man i like it
because it's fun no it is fun i i used
to like it
i also like attack on titan oh hello
so what are you gonna say next what's
your favorite slice of life
why what what's your what's your what no
no no
no no we're not done here what is your
what is your psychological explanation
for
why i like attack on fighting
a bit i don't know i just i i don't
watch it anymore so i don't know what to
say to be honest
it's because i don't have a [ __ ]
titan before
bro is it because i'm not dating anyone
is that why speaking of titans have you
watched blood of zeus that's pretty good
too
i don't know the words that you're
saying oh no
what did you just say where do you watch
anime
what where do you watch uh in
my couch i usually sit there and there's
a tv no no no no like what servants
oh i go i'm subscribed to all of them i
i use like
animation verve crunchyroll
netflix amazon prime video
hulu oh oh oh okay i i i'll give you
psychological uh
anime have you seen um anohana
need to i got i got
six episodes in front and then we
stopped watching
oh really it really picks up in the end
actually
oh yeah yeah i would keep watching it
so yeah if you said i [ __ ] love
anahana i'd be like
that's so carson
[Laughter]
you've known me for two hours it's the
kind of show that will make you cry
but i watched it and i just realized
yeah i'm dirty i can't
er this does nothing for me now but if i
was your age i would cry
you you feel me i'm not a child i'm
above you that's what i'm saying i don't
cry like a little
baby like you were you don't try
anything
and never cry really
yeah chad said it makes everyone yeah
it's it's a side enemy
it makes it makes you cry oh you know
what anime actually makes me cry
what haiku it's a volleyball anime
[ __ ] if you don't cry if that does not
make you cry you're not human
but it's okay why would it make you cry
have you seen it yeah yeah yeah but it's
like hype
it's not it's not like yeah it's like
[ __ ] yeah you want to smash the ball
[ __ ] yeah this is beautiful oh my god
like i'm i'm gonna start crying oh no no
no no
how many seasons how much did you want
uh
i i got through the third season ah what
the [ __ ] you're not human
watch the dub ah that's the problem you
watch the dub
gotcha all right problem solved
now that gets me emotional for some
reason i'm like damn this is so
beautiful
i mean i don't know i don't know what
that says about me i don't have any
psychological
like [ __ ] great i think it's i think
it's like 10 out of 10 [ __ ]
hell yeah so like i'm right there with
you but i i guess it's like if i know a
show wants to make me cry
and i'm like i'm too smart for this i
know what you're doing
[Laughter]
see i'm i'm i'm the opposite i'm
covering the presents [ __ ]
i fall straight into their trap if i
want to
watch it like 5am to make myself more
willing to be
oh okay nice [ __ ] everyone said i ruined
it
sorry what i ruined it
oh yeah i i didn't really know what you
were doing
do you have uh do you have an anime list
yeah oh dude let's compare him what's
your name
uh call me carson [ __ ] yeah
finally someone had one i'm asking all
my friends uh it's pewdie
where's the pie ah this is old school
before the pie came
cutie let's see if i have my login
you've watched more than me you [ __ ]
loser i'm older
you're also you've also had a decade
more
now that i think about it it makes a lot
more sense
uh all right let's see here
can we i know there's a thing where you
can compare like how we rate anime
well i rate them all badly because i
watch a lot of garbage on purpose
uh because i like you're a harsh critic
no was they call me carson
uh or what was it sorry
would you like a link uh i
think i got it it should be
i should have sunglasses in the in the
picture
uh it's very slow i think a lot of
people went on
yeah i think you're right
oh nice nice
okay it is not loading for me
we have 60 shared that's pretty good
really 60 60.2
wow bro you don't rate your your
oh it's planned to watch they're just
dying
oh no
oh no i got you that's embarrassing oh
god
well
oh did you did you cry at a koenig
silent voice a style voice is [ __ ]
the bomb.com dude
hell yeah i love that movie that's like
that's like my favorite movie that's art
dude from
from top to bottom i'm with you i
watched out on a plane and i cried
even though i've seen it twice
it's so good i never see yeah i've never
seen a show that handled bullying so
well
ah i'm glad i'm glad you agree on that
yeah that's amazing you know what you
know what you're okay
we did it the oven is ready
oh yeah but speaking of the oven being
ready
it's the tree ready well i think the
tree might be ready let's okay
let's not overdo it uh
let's uh let's have a have a look at it
um but what i was gonna say nice
you know what not bad no
honestly i like it i like it a lot
yeah did you put it in your festive mood
yeah no i'm feeling happy holidays yeah
merry christmas everyone
what i was gonna say about the oven
being ready is i tweeted something that
you said was weird
and it was uh about you and marzia
having a baby
now that i've talked to you i agree it's
weird wait i don't get it oh
uh to say that yeah
[Applause]
that's all right but i thought the the
concept of
you needing my blessing was humorous i
got that
i got that yeah
same page yeah don't worry it's all good
it's yeah it didn't turn out bad i
i wouldn't post this on my top top
creations if i had to make like a
montage or anything
oh i would okay top one
like if i did a top one montage this
would be top
one
what if i did a christmas tree montage
this would be at the top oh yeah if we
did a christmas tree montage this would
definitely
be at the top all right yeah
yeah thanks for coming on hey
i appreciate it don't burn the trio okay
i'm genuinely not going to especially
because i've got to
write a sign under it that says
pewdiepie and carson's
tree yeah wait put me back in so i can
see it
yeah and then we'll do it
like right here
uh pewds and
carson's carson's
christmas tree
and then the date is 12 16
20 20.
well done hey screenshot where
where i don't know wait i can't see
myself there we go
[ __ ] it's all confusing maybe we should
stand a little bit further back right
oh yes or maybe not
all right i was gonna do it next to the
sign
and you and me okay okay okay okay okay
perfect perfect that's
that's smart smart there you go
hell yeah i was gonna have you over mine
but maybe we can do that another time
what oh i'm down whenever bro okay just
hit me up
all right well it's fun yeah good
talking to you man
yeah thanks for coming on my pleasure
good luck i'm sorry it was awful
for the first hour good luck on your
let's play podcast thanks man
all right take care man later but
all right you guys have a good time
let's leave let's leave this creep
uh that was fun
i know i know the whole carson's whole
stick is to be as awkward as possible
and i know the whole chat was like
crunch cringe but it was
i liked it i had a good time
um thanks for watching
some epic minecraft we've got more
minecraft stuff coming up tomorrow
look at the graph
and uh yeah i'm gonna go take
uh am i on me yeah
keep the new g fuel cup hell yeah coming
soon
prophase
you